الصراع الصيني الامريكي عنوان مو غريب ولا
جديد ولكن يبدو انه بنشهد حلقه جديده من
حلقاته وفصل جديد من فصول المواجهه
الصينيه الامريكيه واحدث المواجهات هذه
نقدر نسميها حرب المناطيط القصه بدات قبل
اسابيع وقت تمرس المنطاد بالسماء الولايات
المتحده وشكوا فيه واتهموا الصين انها هي
اللي ارسلته للتجسس وقامت بعدين امريكا
واسقطته بصاروخ وطلعت الصين واستنكرت اللي
صار وقالت ردت الفعل اللي عملتها امريكا
مبالغ فيها وانه المنطاد هذا انحرف عن
مساره وان هو اصلا مخصص للارصاد الجويه
فقط الموضوع احتد لمن الايام الماضيه
امريكا اعلنت عن اسقاط ثلاثه اجسام طائره
مجهوله جديده واحده فوق الاسكا ثاني بوب
كندا والثالث على الحدود الامريكيه
الكنديه وباحجام واشكال مختلفه فالاول كان
بحجم سياره صغيره والثاني كان اسطواني اما
الثالث فكان بوصول بسلاسل متصله وطبعا
اصابع الاتهام اتوجهت الصين اللي عندها
اسطول من المناطيط وطلع المتحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي وقال انه
تم اسقاط الاجسام الطائره المجهوله حفاظا
على امن الولايات المتحده من التجسس وما
بيستبعدوا نصين ارسلتها لغرض المراقبه
الصين من جانبها في تماما انه اصلا بتتجسس
على امريكا وبيتاكد انه المنطاد الاول او
حتى الثلاثه اجسام الجديده ما لها علاقه
فيهم وانها اصلا في سنه 2022
رصدت الصين في سمائها عشره مناطيد امريكيه
وتصرفت معاها المهنيه ومسؤوليه
امريكا اللي اصلا قالت انه من قبل الحادثه
المنطاد هادي في مناطيت كثيره صينيه
لقطوها باجوائهم وخاصه في حكم ترامب طلعت
ونفذ كلام الصين عن عشره مناطيد امريكيه
باجوائها
تدخل في القصه وطلع الامين العام للحلف
وقال انه اللي بيصير في الولايات المتحده
بخصوص المناطيس الصينيه هو جزء من نمط
بتكون في الصين وروسيا لزياده انشطه
المراقبه على حلف شمال الاطلسي وبداوا
اصلا حبايب امريكا كمان يتجمعوا حولها ضد
الصين كندا من الاول ماخذه امريكا وتم
اسقاط اجسام فيها اصلا اليابان من ساعات
طلعت تكلمت قالت انه هي كمان رصد من 2019
ثلاثه مناطيد صينيه في اجواءها الصين
مسكتت ابدا وطلع المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه وقال انه المنطاد الاول الصيني
دخل المجال الجوي الامريكي عن طريق الخطا
اما الباقيين فما بيعرفوا عنهم اي شيء
وقال لما يتعلق الامر بمراقبه البلدان
الاخرى ومراقبتها فالولايات المتحده هي
امبراطوريه المراقبه
نحب هذه تحتاج نقاش عشان نفهمها فمعنا من
القاهره دكتور محمد فايز فرحات مدير مركز
الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه اهلا فيك معنا الدكتور ايش
رايك في هذه الحرب هل نقدر فعلا نقول انه
في حرب بين امريكا والصين وانه المناطين
هي جالس السلاح فيها
يعني بالفعل يعني يمكن الاطلاق يعني او
وصف هذه ما يحدث منها هذه ظاهره بالفعل
باننا اذا يعني حرب مناطيد يعني العلاقات
الامريكيه الصينيه اصبحت يعني تحتمل
الكثير من التوصيفات يعني كما نعلم يعني
في منتصف عام 2018 كان هناك حديث عن الحرب
التجاريه بين الصين والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يعني تاريخ العلاقات مليء بهذا
النوع من المفاهيم واعتقد ان حاله التوتر
او التدهور الذي طال العلاقات الامريكيه
الصينيه خلال السنوات الاخيره والمتوقع ان
يشهد مزيد من التدهور خلال الفتره المقبله
اعتقد انه يفتح المجال امام يعني مثل هذا
النوع من المفاهيم بالاضافه الى ذلك فان
على ما يبدو ان المناطيد يعني كان يتم
استخدامها منذ فتره ربما ما حدث فقط هو ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه قررت ان
تتعامل الان بطريقه او بالاداء العسكريه
ضد هذه المناطيل وهذا سؤال مطروح داخل
الكونجرس الامريكي يعني الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تتحدث عن ان كان هناك مناطيد او
ان يعني البناطيد الصينيه يعني كانت معتاد
عليها او جرى استخدامها لفتره او منذ فتره
طويله والصين نفسها تتحدث عن ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يعني كان هناك مناطيد
تدخل الاجواء الصينيه ولكن لم لم يتم
التعامل معها او وفقا للتعبير الصيني كان
يتم التعامل
الدكتور محمد انه التصرف والرد على هذه
المناطيل واسقاطها تصعيد من الولايات
المتحده
هو هو تصعيد واعتقد انه مفهوم يعني مفهوم
في سياق التدهور القائم في العلاقات بين
الجانبين هناك رسائل كل طرف يسعى الى
توصيل رسائل شديده الوضوح للطرف الاخر
فيما يتعلق بسقف او يعني
سقف توقعات الطرف الاخر بالنسبه لسلوكها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اراد التوصيل
رساله واضحه بانها بدات تكون على استعداد
اكبر لاستخدام القوه العسكريه في سياق
العلاقات القائمه بين الجانبين صحيح انه
يتم استخدام القوه العسكريه ضد
جسم صيني ويتم داخل الاجواء الامريكيه وهو
حق يعني للولايات المتحده الامريكيه لكن
لم يكن يتم استخدام هذه الاداه او الاداه
العسكريه قبل ذلك بل لم يكن يتم الكشف
عنها لكن الان اصبحت الامور تتم بدرجه
اكبر من العلني العل درجه اكبر من الوضوح
وتوظيف رسائل او توظيف ادوات جديده في
العلاقات او في الصراع بين الجانبين احنا
خلينا بس نذكر ان الصين جلسه بتنفي هذا
الكلام لكن اذا افتراضا انه مشينا مع
الروايه الامريكيه انه ارسال من امريكا
لكندا لليابان ليش ارسال المناطيل هذه
كلها طب ما في وسائل مختلفه اخرى للتجسس
يعني
المناطيد لها خصوصيه بالمقارنه بها
الاقمار الاصطناعيه البناطيد ارخص من حيث
التكلفه
بالمقارنه بالاقمار الاصطناعيه ايضا فيما
يتعلق
بامكانيات تحليقها على مستويات اقل من
الاقمار الصناعيه ربما هذا يكون له يعني
تاثير فيما يتعلق بجوده الصور او غيرها
لكن في المجمل الميزه الاساسيه التي تميز
المناطيد انها اقل من حيث التكلفه
بالمقارنه بالادوات الاخرى هذا يعني ما
يفسر الاعتماد على اليه المناطيد رغم جميع
الاطراف تعتمد على الاليات الاخرى جميع
الاطراف تعتمد على توظيف يعني الادوات
الاخرى في التجسس لكن على ما يبدو ان
المناطيض ما زال تحتفظ ببعض الميزات التي
تفسر اعتماد جميع الاطراف على هذه الظاهره
او هذه الاداه طيب اذا رحنا للروايه
الصينيه اللي هي بتنفي وجلسه حتى بتقول
انه يعني معليش انتو يا الولايات المتحده
يعني انتم اصلا امبراطوريين او انتو
امبراطوريه
المراقبه يعني فلا تقعدوا ترموا التهم
علينا هل بتصدق هذا الموضوع منهم او نفيهم
يعني اعتقد الروايه الصينيه يعني او سرديه
الصينيه ضعيفه منذ ان بدات يعني كان هناك
يعني في البدايه كان هناك حتى تردد في او
يعني تغير في التبرير الصيني كان هناك نفي
ثم هناك كان هناك يعني تبرير ثم التاكيد
الان ورد الدكتور محمد معلش بس ورد عاجل
الان من البيت الابيض بيقول لا مؤشرات على
انه الاجسام التي تم اسقاطها مرتبطه
ببرنامج تجسس صيني كانه تراجع في الموقف
الامريكي
يعني اعتقد هذا ينصرف على الاجسام الثلاثه
الاخيره التي تم يعني ضربها او تدميرها
لكن اعتقد فيما يتعلق بالمنطاد الصيني
الصين نفسها لم ترفض او لم تنفي انقاذ هو
منطاد صيني فقط الاختلاف بين الجانبين
يتعلق بما اذا كان مهمتهم مهمه مدنيه او
تتعلق يعني بانشطه تتعلق
بالمهام بحثيه ام انه منطاد لاهداف عسكريه
لكن الصين لم تنفي ان هذا المنطاد هو مضاد
صيني طب بالعوده لحديثك اللي كنت تتحدث
فيه عن
التبرير الصيني او رفض الصيني لهذه
الاتهامات تقدر تكمل فكرتك لو سمحت
نعم يعني اعتقد ان الروايه الصينيه كما
اشرت قبل ذلك كانت ضعيفه منذ البدايه
واعتقد ان هذا الامر فقط يتعلق بالتغير
الذي حدث فيما يتعلق بمواقف الاطراف او
طريقه تعامل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
مع الظاهره لكن الواضح ان اليه المناطيد
كان يتم استخدامها بكثافه من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ومن جانب الصين ايضا ما
يحدث او الجديد ايضا ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تستخدم هذه الظاهره الجديده
لخلق مناء راي عام عالمي ضد هذه الظاهره
وضد الصين يعني نلاحظ ان اليابان بدات ترد
فعل او بدات يعني تتحدث عن ان هناك اجسام
تم رصدها منذ سنوات في عام 2019 او في
السنوات الاخيره
كندا تحدثت عن نفس الامر لدخول حلف الناتو
فالواضح او التطور الجديد في هذا الاطار
ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تريد توظيف
هذه الظاهره لخلق للتاكيد على
خلق مناخ او اطار او يعني ري عامي ضد
الصين
طيب احنا بنشكرك على هذه المداخله كان
معنا دكتور محمد فايز فرحات مدير مركز
الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه والاستيراتيه
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]